first of all let's bring out Seth
Green right behind zth green Michael
tro right behind Michael my dear friend
from the G4 Network rip uh Allison Hy
SL yeah right here
you will recognize this next man from
his vase and also his voice Nolan
North they said theot that's what they
said also making his I believe this is
the seventh con that he's been to Casper
Van
de ah
crap Chris did I Chris yeah listen I got
information before I walked out here to
leave two two seats at the end of the
panel I didn't realize they were all
going to be named now now this is very
awkward it's awkward yeah that's fine
you know let's just figure it out the
most of most of the hour and a half will
just be people figuring out where
they're supposed to sit please save all
of your questions we got of time for
this uh I'd also like to bring to the
stage someone that I know you guys know
Trisha
Halper squee so we're all getting moved
out also the amazing and hilarious Cindy
Sterling uh my dear friend and sometimes
cooworker Felicia
Day gentlemen sincerely one of my oldest
friends in the world and my old roommate
when we were in college will
weaton
oh my God thanks for Kermit flailing out
onto the stage
real yay also uh want to bring up some
of the makeup and effects guys let's
first bring out Barry
Bishop followed by Billy
Brooks
yeah also PJ and Sky
HMA
um a young upand cominging actor that I
think you guys are going to enjoy by the
name of Nathan
fillian and then finally uh the man
whose idea birthed this in Nathan's
kitchen uh please welcome to the stage
Alan
T
yeah seat the
end
yes set that up
costume we're wait wait wait a second
wait a second if you tell us to leave
two seats at the end and then you sit on
that end then we just look like like
jerks so why don't you come down there's
two seats there's two seats saf for you
guys at the end of the
table he's down there SL
now again
I'm quick like
lightning okay now Michael you trade
with Will Felicia you trade with SE
noan by the way this is now the first
and last web series in Hall
h you guys just very important I got to
address this I'm sorry drank out of it
hold on a second guys
hold the phone Allan you're wearing the
wrong
costume wait what are you tell what I'm
saying this this character that the
costume we're wearing is uh
he's they don't want you to say it he's
he's
sleeping with baby
Jesus
sorry
Alan Allan you misunderstood you
misunderstood you're playing a new pilot
now oh you mean cash I mean
cash you mean this guy
hold
yeah yeah not enough
room
there we
go there's ketchup on the floor over
here just uh it's going to be a clean up
on I five thank
you that is amazing two Jump suits in
the heat of San Diego in July I'm also
wearing long underwear just you know
it's good idea keep it hot so this is
this is Cash yes cash is the character
that you play in the web series version
of a show that's not at all if there's
any people from Fox here like Firefly uh
show called Spectrum yes so people
haven't really seen anything yet right
cuz you did the campaign and then you
guys immediately started shooting and so
no one's really seen anything of con man
yet why don't we show
them this
is never before seen footage they
literally just finished putting it
together 20 hours ago this is as fresh
out of the oven as possible let's take a
look at a sneak peek of conman Allan uh
congratulations on the series it look I
mean it looks genuine it looks
amazing much how did you what what where
did the idea like really what the story
behind the idea and how did you get it
from Nathan's kitchen to Hall
age ah that is a good question um uh I
started going to conventions right after
Firefly was cancelled uh in
2002 it's it's boo is right it's not new
news but yeah it still sucks um uh so I
started going to conventions then and
then I I was coming to conventions from
an outsider perspective cuz I was in New
York uh without a TV and uh thinking I
was all artistic and uh did Firefly got
introduced Nathan invited me and uh it
was fantastic and then slowly over
time it just started germinating you
just started looking around a lot of
people will look around at the
conventions and say God somebody needs
to make a show about this cuz it's so
much fun it's so Fantastical you could
do a comedy there's so many amazing
characters especially behind the scenes
so it just slowly every convention I
would go to I go oh that's an idea oh I
could do that like the the doll
convention was a real thing um in
Florida and I really it's just like that
I was in Florida say no more
okay so it it happened like that and
then it was also an opportunity to get
in a spaceship again with this guy and
uh it's kind of a a a backd door way of
uh getting on a space show uh so but but
but I feel like like you you got this
would have to be the group to make a
show like this because you know most of
the entertainment industry when they
look at our little bubble they don't
have the they don't they don't represent
it in the right way they they sort of
make fun of it as opposed to like
they're laughing at us as opposed to
like no this is all we're all part of
this community and these are you know
like we can laugh with each other about
about what they're like so I think it
was just the right person hadn't come
along to really have The Insider point
of view well it's um thank you and uh
totally agree totally agree um uh but it
was also the crowdfunding uh we couldn't
have been made uh through a normal
studio just for those same reasons that
this gave us a lot of control to make it
the way we knew it should be made
because we've been going to conventions
for over a decade and so it it wasn't a
foreign idea to us we've been meeting
fans for so long that that uh we felt
like we could honor it and uh poke fun
at it in a fun way like the the the
Tooth Fairy who burned down his village
uh I've met a lot of amazing fans who
have actually had a connection with
firefly and have they've it's changed
you know it helped them through tough
times whether it's a soldier or someone
just whatever different things from
different people and uh so that's a guy
who had a tough time uh helped him
forget about his village because he
burned it down
and uh so it's the same it's the world
and taking some reality a little nugget
of reality and going just a little bit
farther cuz the world allows for so much
so much fun did you ever pitch it to
television yeah yeah and so when when
the crowdfunding happened you rais $3.2
million did you call those Studios and
tell them to S on a d because you just
raised 3.2 million and that they're
wrong and stupid wait can we say s on a
d you can say s on a d on a d
what does that mean that could mean a
lot of things it does yeah slip on a
donut that's what I'm that's what that's
what I'm you go slip on a donut
sir in your f um in my
f your Falafel oh good right right sorry
I was born without an F I don't like to
talk about it uh no I did not but um I'm
hoping this amazing turnout in this uh
impressive venue
yeah
yeah it's such a you know they can come
to their own conclusions I don't need to
stoop to that level so uh let's start
going down the line Nathan how when did
when this when this idea when when it
came to fruition in your kitchen would
you immediately go we have to do
something with this I need to be
involved with this I remember saying
when I remember the day when Allan stole
my
idea
and listen uh how did I say it
earlier they say a little hard work
never killed anyone I say why take any
chances but Allan wasn't afraid to say
you no you know what I'm going to call
PJ up right now and get him to do some
hard
work uh it was an idea that Allan would
not let it die and uh soon enough he had
written a couple of episodes one uh the
first one he polished up really nicely
he cast a little read through he went to
his house and it was really enjoyable we
really liked it and it just never
stopped until these guys took over and
then it really didn't
stop yeah my my girlfriend has had to
listen for quite some time now sentences
that start with in con
man oh I got an idea in con man uh it's
been going on for a while it's really I
I haven't caught up with this I can't
catch up with this guys what the hell
man well
and I think I like when you look at the
panel of people here and also obviously
in the trailer there's a ton more people
it feels like everyone this was a thing
that everyone already wanted to do
whether or not they knew it it was like
oh we have to get in there and make fun
of ourselves uh play around with this
world you were almost in it several
times I wanted to be in it so bad but my
my I but my work schedule is oppressive
and I don't have a life you have you do
a lot of work yeah no it's unable it's
not a big deal it's dumb
uh you're busy yeah I talk about zombies
and give out points it doesn't matter uh
but uh but it's a shut up I say points
you don't say
points
uh how dare you that's my
art uh so let's just kind of go down the
line and find out like how everyone got
involved and you know was this a type of
a show that you had always thought
should exist let's start with you
Michael um yeah I well what you said
just now that everybody wants to be a
part of this and I don't think Allan you
realize how much we all wanted to be a
part of this uh it was actually this
year at your birthday party at Nathan's
birthday party when PJ approached me at
a party the producer down there and he
says um he goes tro you know Allan's
kind of reluctant to ask you know
friends for a favor would you want to be
you know maybe do an episode or just do
something in comment and I'm looking at
PJ going dude I will be the bus boy who
brings more butter to the table it you
know I would do this in a heartbeat
because I feel like this is tapping into
the zeit right now of of this popular
culture and this is a this is a kind of
show that people are going to want to be
a part of and it was such a no-brainer
man and I got to just tell you I'm so
grateful to be here and to been a part
of it and and and my favorite part of
the story is that I worked before Trisha
did and she told me uh that Allan was
talking about the scene that I had with
Nathan and he goes I didn't know true K
was
funny so maybe that's why you were
reluctant to ask me he's hysterical he's
not in this uh trailer we're going to
hopefully uh be able to put him out and
there's going to be a couple more
trailers as we near uh September 30th
and he's hysterical it was like a page
and a half to two-page scene that is now
a five-page scene because you and Nathan
uh you play a cop who pulls Nathan over
and uh so much of so much of what he
does was his own thing you know coming
up to the car sir put your hands on the
on the put your hands on the wheel oh my
God you're Jack Moore I almost shot
you you did he's a yeah he's a cop with
aggression issues yeah for sure I'm
working it out I'm working but I mean
that's very sweet but all that being
said the the the the skeleton the the
the the framework of this thing is
because of Allan and because of his
genius it's true man it's absolutely
true it's
fantastic can we say shus or something
like that because yeah schmus Seth Green
Oh hey what's up guys who do you who do
you who do you play uh in the com oh I
just I told I said I'd do whatever
honestly it was kind of the same Theory
I had uh picked up that Funko wash last
uh San Diego Comic Con I told Allan that
I had it for him and then he was like oh
we should grab dinner or something and
then like eight months go by and then
eventually he's like hey we should do
that dinner and while we're at dinner
he's like hey I know everybody's not
really into crowdsourcing stuff but what
if we crowdsourced like a really cool
project and got all the people that we
know in it and it was about cons and I
was like all right literally whatever
you want I'll do
it so I play uh comic store owner Casey
W Casey Wing wall who's hosting a mini
con and uh I got uh Michael Dorne and
Kevin Grievous on stage
doing epic characters and then Allan's
in the middle doing characters from a
show that nobody saw that was old and
had incredibly outdated interpretations
of ethnic uh
stereotypes what's up [__] y'all didn't
see that what's up [__] that was the
cartoon the P the panel is called
something like exploring uh bigoted
imagery in hate
art
I think that you you contributed to that
uh that name didn't you did I I wait it
was on the thing maybe a question I'll
take credit for anything in this no this
it was all your idea dude just your
puppets basically you had written it who
who who was involved who was everyone
who was involved with the writing
process and how much how much did you
guys Riff on set I wrote them and then
there was a lot of riffing on set Nolan
North uh
uh I don't think he has one line that I
wrote maybe one two uh so he doesn't
respect authority that's good yeah I I
he plays I mean he'll tell you he plays
Jerry Lancing the map King uh who's the
second best motion capture artist in the
world behind that son of a [__] uh Andy
Circus
uh
charlatan he's taking all the good
monkey rolls man yeah it's all he does
monkeys
you want a monkey call him uh but uh
yeah people people it was it was really
free since there was nobody in charge
but me I and PJ and you know Nathan we
could just say whatever we wanted like
Milo vent migy you saw him on his motor
that motorcycle that's his he showed up
to work in that motorcycle I was like
hey can we just put that in here he's
like love to let's put it in there and
then that was that can I put some yogurt
in I'm going to put some yogurt in this
dumpster and then uh costume's like no
no no you can't here you're going to get
it on your shirt we only have one of
those yeah yeah I just talked to the
director he said it's
okay so easy do you like did you like
having that much responsibility where
you were supposed to be the guy with all
the answers you know what I mean like
everyone's looking to you because it's
your project is that was was that
overwhelming or did you kind of glide
into it
seamlessly no I didn't Glide there was
no
gliding
uh yeah uh it is amazing when you're
doing all when you're wearing all of
those that's how much needs to be
cleared through you I couldn't believe
it walking across set everybody would
grab you and go uh this cuff or this
cuff uh here's the here's the mockup for
the spaceship thing oh that's great uh
oh Alan we need to work on the stickers
this is going to be at uh we have bacon
and we have um uh xcon or two of our
cons and uh here's the signage for that
this color and thator would just never
it was really unbelievable and then you
and you're walking on the way to the set
to go all right let's do this scene so
it it was overwhelming uh but what so is
this no how many episodes did you end up
making it was 120 minutes so we kind of
called it a movie as we were going along
because it felt like a movie um so it's
12 10-minute episodes but they're really
they're written as half hour episodes uh
with three acts so we're releasing them
that way too and three uh releasing too
in three uh episodes at a time so you
can watch the story arc and so we did
four half hours excellent uh Allison
hlip one of my dear friends from the now
defunct G4 Network a rip may it rest in
peace um so what what do you do in con
man and how did you get involved well I
was actually here in San Diego about a
month and a half ago my friends got
married down here on a Friday night and
Saturday morning I was very hung over
and driving back to LA and all a sudden
I get a phone call from Alan tudk and I
assume it's a butt dial so I'm like why
would Alan be calling me at 11:00 a.m.
on a Saturday morning and we get on the
phone and he's like Allison what are you
doing Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
this week I'm like I'm going to be in
New York why he's like oh man I wanted
to offer you this role on con man I'm
like I'm canceling my flight I'll be
there so I found out less than 48 hours
beforehand that I was shooting and uh so
what I found out two days later was that
I am faith and I am uh Jack Moore's
assistant his personal assistant but
Jack Moore is never where he's supposed
to be so instead I show up and Jack
Moore is on
FaceTime you know what was your
experience like working with this group
oh it was amazing well I was there day
one right we were day one of shooting
stuff yeah and we set up the first scene
and Alan's like uh okay uh
action and I I actually had the very
first line recorded on the entire show
and it didn't occur to me until after we
cut that first scene that I was like oh
that was like a lot of pressure Alison
you just kicked off this whole thing
because it was one line in that entire
scene too right I think yeah I don't
know yeah Alison yes yes you did would
you take us there I know but let me tell
you day two on that set we spent like 7
hours in a heated saltwater infinity
pool in Malibu in the most perfect
weather ever and it was like the
greatest day of my life I was like
nothing change please ever they were
like you want we're not gonna We're not
gonna shoot for 15 minutes you want to
get out I'm like no staying in the pool
is way cooler and going back to makeup
you know do you want to go to the did
you get super pruny by the end oh I was
so water locked driving home that day
you know you have like water stuck in
your head and you're just like like
driving on the 405 like trying to shake
it out worth it uh Casper how did you
get involved in the project and who are
you noan oh no but Nolan but Nolan said
Stu
he's the he's the the second most
popular um after behind that son of a
[__] Andy Cirus after after monkey I
was Tarzan so I was another monkey go
ahead noan noan tell them how we met I
was their fourth
choice no Nolan and I met uh when we
were recording Young Justice the first
time yeah and uh then we we worked
together Mo motion capturing um uh what
was
that
Uncharted and uh yeah wo I was going to
be an Uncharted you're you're the main
dude I am the main dude in Uncharted in
so many other things you you know Nolan
from so many other things no uh if you
knew what he did oh
um so I was I had written a character
named uh Nigel thce uh who was the
second best uh motion capture person and
uh and then I'm when I when we started
motion capturing you were doing this
character named Jerry Lancing who was
also a motion capture he was map King
and it was a very similar character to
Nigel thce and after a couple of months
of working together uh it was just
obvious that you had to play Nigel th
and we changed his name to Jerry Lancing
uh yeah and I mean you had been living
the character for years of of being moap
King uh hello G I want to say Jim yes no
well Jerry Lansing was a character that
in between takes of this um Uncharted
motion capture game um just to cut up
and goof around because I could um just
came up with him he's just this you know
pompous self-righteous um never knew
anyone by the you know Adam Norman good
to see you love your work
Sean and it just and it just it was
literally just something that I would I
would make up stuff just to just to keep
loose and um when Allan and I worked
together he yeah it was it's along the
same lines as everybody else's story he
would uh he said you know would you do
this and it was like absolutely I'm like
do I have to pay you are there any do I
need to be clothed um it didn't matter
it was it was unbelievable opportunity
because in all the on camera stuff I've
done I'm always the doctor or um the
lawyer or I don't get the part
um uh and this was my first opportunity
and I think almost 20 years to do
something funny and and um that's who I
always felt you know that's where I
belong so I mean I I owe so much I'm so
grateful as as everybody I'm sure but so
grateful to be doing this and uh I think
people are going to absolutely love it
because he's one of the funniest people
I've ever met and just the stuff he does
he hasn't met many people though really
people don't stay away small Social
Circle and and Casper
plays the the
bartender the the bartender uh four
different times you're the Perpetual
bartender in every just it's at a bar
and then we go someplace and he's the
bartender at Another Place Another
episode there's a bartender he's always
the
bartender wherever we go God bless you
for doing
that best job I ever had he's your uh
he's your loveboat Isaac character
basically no matter what there on that
guy is there yeah how he get holog yeah
first of all Casper uh damn your perfect
face hair and jawline
um look at that how dare you come in
here with that
uh but those to what was the what was
the experience like for you and how and
how did you how did you kind of weave in
and what what did you bring oh they they
they just asked for my jaw to come in
and just it it's the first school of
acting I I I went to it's just for just
for the jaw it's perfect um and so
luckily I didn't have to speak in
this it smells good
too Casper yeah that's
that this is what I do in the movie The
Show yeah just making drinks bar he just
making tant bar that's what bartenders
do this is all I do his role his Ro
jokes the bottom the bottom I know right
stop
that is turning into seven yeah take
that off yeah yeah damn it yeah no come
back to him come back to him
yeah that's what I'm talking about and
Men yeah I wipe that
off Casper Just So You Know Your Role is
much larger if we do more of these
there's a there's a reason who you
there's a you are someone important that
it it is unil thank you I always wanted
to be someone
important now I've I've got validation
here at Comic-Con you all heard
it finally been validated it's only took
me TW taken me uh 27
years yeah yep what yep I a valid I'm
not validated anymore no you're valid
valid oh you're absolutely validated
you're a big you're a big character I
know no I appr appreciate it thank you
this was a lot of fun my my manager
called me up and he said hey do you want
to do this thing you you uh get to work
with these these people here and uh you
don't say
anything you have one
line you've got it you've got one line
you delivered it
amazingly I have one line it sort of
feels like the whole thing is populated
with basically just everyone that people
love just like it basically is just like
a it's like a love letter to cons and
fan favorites it sounds like there's
like everyone is some someone that
people love and
recognize yes and and a lot of people
play versions of themselves uh Sean
Aston plays himself himself but he's
like a heavy drinker and uh he gives bad
advice and uh that's not Sean Aston at
all um Milo uh Milo I hope if we could
ever you know you know there's I have
plans for his character too just offet
there was they had four passports and
some foreign currency that was going to
possibly be part of his character that
he's just going through the passports he
picks up the phone yeah the bear walks
in the
woods it's worse than I thought throws
the cell phone down destroys it what the
hell is going on don't ask too many
questions Alan so you know I I hope to
have him repelling down buildings and
stuff uh will will um uh is not his
character is not incredibly large in
this in this Incarnation but uh he's
he's a Smuggler and uh he would appear
here in another episode that's actually
uh very close to being it's halfway
finished so so yeah excellent uh Trisha
how did you get involved with the
project and do you play yourself or do
you play someone else well um first as
as having been to some conventions
myself I always thought there was a
plethora of things that you could do so
um it was quite a few months ago
actually that I got an email from Allan
uh asking saying saying that he was
doing this writing this and um that
there was a character that he kind of
wrote with me in mind or thought of me
for and of course it was an immediate
yes that like everyone here said he's
incredibly funny so uh I didn't even
have to read it but of course I did and
I was I assumed I would be playing a
robot in a red dress or maybe a green
dress to change things up you know turn
it a little christmy or something but um
no I'm playing
Louise and uh Louise likes conventions
as well and but she goes to can I say
Alan oh yeah you yeah we say it in the
trailer it's a doll convention she goes
to doll conventions um I go I I go to
doll conventions so we we we go on a
date and we we have a little bit of fun
but uh I I don't come across as
necessarily having a doll to begin with
it's it's a thing it's called reborn
and so I was I was actually very pleased
that I got to play somebody not not like
myself even though I kind of come off
like myself a little bit comedy I mean
you get to see Trisha do a comedy I I've
never seen that before and you're very
funny I mean all the way to Pratt Falls
and stuff physical comedy and stuff it's
going to be uh I can't wait for people
to see it yeah I I was very excited to
get to do some comedy and and also for
you to think of me that way and then I
thought wait what is he trying to tell
me that he thought of me while he was
writing this
role there's some hidden meaning in
there that I haven't quite figured out
but uh onset it was super fun and and um
I will say that Alan got me to kiss in a
way I've never got to kiss
before what's that have to wait and
see she said she you got her to kiss in
a way that she's never kissed before
that is
true uh uh it's oh Trisha I just wrote
this one extra scene uh it it was
written we a lot of film so we're just
going to take this until we get it
right uh took a week to get that uh yeah
yeah
yeah much respect we did that scene
too everybody had to do that scene it
was part
of you guys I sincerely apologize I have
to go to another panel what panel are
you going to I know I know I'm over
booked but I do want to say Alan it's
all for you I love you a lot this thing
is amazing I can't wait for everybody
ready to see it by Seth Green Green Drop
the
mic there you go
nice get out you get out of here how
dare you don't hug him get out of here
Seth Green get stop touching people
leave how dare you you get out of here
Seth and don't you come back you got the
red light got look everybody's leaving
no don't you sit
down how dare you yeah Nolan and I got
time we're good Seth oh no she's
stalking Seth that's why okay got it uh
totally makes sense I feel like I've
lost my son
a we can build you another one those
redheads stick together uh no Seth Green
is dead forget about him he'd want us to
move
on Mindy Sterling how did you get
involved with the project and and what
do you what do you do for a living no I
know what you do for a living you're one
of the funniest people I've ever met in
my life what do you do for cond man well
I um I think I am the only one on the
panel that never met or knew who Alan
dudic
was doing
here I mean I saw him in some you know
series and stuff but um I I really did
not we did we were not friends we had no
history I didn't owe him anything
um so uh my call
was uh first you know through my agent
you want to do this thing it's about
Comic Con and you know scraped and I
read it and I loved it I absolutely
loved it I to done and still do cons so
um I really did love it and uh was very
excited I L the whole campaign and how
it was created I it was very very
different I love different I love dark
so this is perfect for me and um so I
play
Bobby the very very colorful sort of
she's dying to be his talent manager con
manager uh agent whatever she can get
her hands on uh a little controlling uh
likes to sleep around um uh wears every
episode is she wears a different
wig um I love doing all of that I found
it fascinating and fun and I think that
Allan and I had met uh I think twice
just to go over the script and
everything before we started working and
I instantly it was just chemistry I just
loved working with him um he always
helped me with my lines while we were
shooting he literally would be on the
other side and mouth my lines for me
because I have a tendency to just blank
and forget and um so yes he would he
would just do that and I would try to
say what what he wanted me to say so I
hope that it came out okay um but I
thought I mean the the every you know
the whole experience was amazing he is
so smart and um he was so in the zone
and yet never yelled never seemed
annoyed uh never seemed like he was
going to
quit um and yet bombarded constantly
with you know little things here and
there so really the most generous and
most um Innovative and interesting
people to work with so I am so glad to
be a part of his hopefully his life now
a wow you get out of here was a good
answer what was your original what was
the original goal for the campaign well
we uh uh PJ uh PJ harma hey PJ hey buddy
um uh we had talked about uh just just
funding the first three Epis episodes
and that that was what it was the first
three episodes because we figured it was
a half hour and that was one story line
and if we could just make that if we
could just make a pilot then people
could get an idea of what it is but
there were four no three more half hour
episodes that were finished at that
point so we could keep going and then it
became I mean because the fans were so
amazing because there was so much
support that we ended we had been
talking about books because PJ's written
four four four four four novels four
sci-fi novels uh prior to this uh and we
wanted to write another book we had
written the first chapter um and by we
wrote he wrote it and I just sit there
and go what about this line um uh and
then comic books we had we a game but
that was all we' all we back burner all
of that but since the fans were so
enthusiastic and uh involved they gave
us a lot of money is what I'm trying to
say um since they gave us so much money
we were able to keep going well if y'all
want we'll do do this and we'll do this
and we'll do this so um we initially
just wanted three 10-minute episodes uh
that was going to be we can make it
it'll it'll we'll be able to show you
what it is and uh now we get to show you
a lot a great deal and we're we're
looking forward to it so you chartered a
jet to Disney World no I mean it's it's
I think when people hear a number like
$3.2 million go it's so much money you
could probably but that money goes
really fast especially if you're trying
to make something of that scope and you
can I mean you could see the like the
show looks amazing so is that like did
you were you amazed at how quickly you
can burn through money when you're
trying to make something PJ um it would
it would go like this when I first read
the script I thought it was the funniest
thing I'd ever read you need a new
microphone PJ I thought it was the
funniest thing I'd ever read but I took
him aside and I go Alan there you've got
a a convention for a scene and he's like
no no don't worry we'll just put up a
curtain they put four people people in
front of a curtain will pretend it's a
convention cut to renting the Long Beach
Convention Center building an entire con
and then and then they call me the night
before I goes remember that scene with
the alien and the cave we just do that
as a as a comic panel I need to do a
real one now so can you get me a cave
can you get me a cave for three lines
for it like did we seriously just put a
cave together for three
lines yeah yeah yeah yeah maybe I should
have written more lines for the cave
scene so I'm not saying I wasted it uh
now you got a sweet cave actually the
cave was free cuz we have a uh an
amazing production designer and she was
she would just she just made things
happen holy crap free cave yeah she goes
I know you know like so is this a real
cave cuz she has a German accident is
this a real cave that you want and I was
like yeah I know how to get a cave
oh I have a cave cave it's orange and it
looks as if it's been shaped by
water great I'll have it for free and so
she she pulled all kinds of strings and
there's on the spaceship some of it is
really really amazing and then like
these things where the there's balls and
whatever um whoa go back to that part
I'm hold on to these
balls uh I have some balls that look as
though they've been shaped by
water oh okay actually very
expensive um but when I fly the
spaceship I pick them up and then you
get all that uh hologram stuff and
that's how you fly fly the spaceship and
turn it um but the things that the ball
set on I think were bottoms of soda
bottles that were painted so you've got
things like that BEC because we were
stretching the budget and then also a
lot of I got that hallway and as she
said this will be the most expensive 20
minutes
ever because about how much we spent we
spent all that anyway I don't want to
say I wasted it no we have that in
storage now by the way it didn't just
get burned at the end it's uh hopefully
we'll make more with the spaceship uh
Felicia I would love to hi Felicia hi
how's it
going
hello
ficia um so when when did you come on
and what did you do and just tell us
stuff okay I'll give it to you um uh
Alan sent me this script about a year
ago actually and because I'm my middle
name is web
series oh web series should it's true
Google it I just I'm I'm that it's it's
in the Wikipedia um so uh he's like hey
I was thinking about doing this a web
series is what do you think is a good
idea and I read it and it was so good
and funny and I could see him in it so
clearly and I was very fortunate to be
in Dr Horrible
uh a little thing um so I had a feeling
when I read the script that he could
blow up the world the way that Dr
Horrible did and I was like oh my God
please do this and um and and I love
breaking the system and the fact that
they decided to do the crowdfunding and
I did it such an amazing way and the
support was incredible and their
consideration to the fans it just blew
me away and of course under underneath
it is all like get me a part uh get me
aart really hire me
uh so Alan called me up and was like I
have this part in the first three
episodes named Karen she works for the
convention and could you do it and um I
we we talked about it on set we actually
had never worked together before but um
but we were in a dollhouse episode in
separate scenes together so so there was
no connection at all before then but we
met at one of Jos Sweden's um
Shakespeare readings yes that was the
first time we ever met Cleopatra where
Mara backer and was Cleopatra she was
Cleopatra she was amazing what sort of
weird crazy lives do you guys lead we
went to Jos Sweden and just did some
shakes bear with marinaa bager and well
you know and then some dragons showed up
like it just
crazy I want I was segueing into
something beautiful Chris I'm sorry
Felicia about how be how it is a family
and people wouldn't think about it but
the actors at cons form a a family we
travel a lot and we see each other and
we hang out and have drinks and it's it
really whenever you know it it just
feels like coming home when you're
hanging with a lot of the crew I mean I
just met you but
uh and you love
me but you form a family on a set and
you form a family at a con and this kind
of has the beautifulness of Both Worlds
combined and I'm so I'm just grateful to
be a part of it so thank you Alan
excellent uh will weon in your Ravenclaw
tie yeah I know me too Ravenclaw the way
gryffindors are
jocks before gryffindors are jocks
ravenclaws are nerds Slytherin are
douchebags and huffle puffs are huffle
Puffs uh what do you want um before I
answer the question can you believe
we're in a Hall h together no it's crazy
it's crazy I mean you know will not to
bore the crap out of you guys but you
know when will and I were teenagers well
will was famous and
uh but we live together in Westwood I we
going to UCLA and we need to get in a
time machine and like Bill in Ted style
go back and just knock on the door of
the apartment on strathore and be like
you guys in like 20 years it's going to
be the coolest thing ever and then our
younger s are going to be like why don't
you guys shave once in a
while who are those
guys so I got um uh uh Nathan texted me
one morning which is a thing I can say
which is really weird and was like Hey
we're I'm Allan and I are doing this
thing and we're going to crowdfund it
and it would be really neat if you would
like just tell Twitter about it and my
response was you don't need me
Nathan like you've got
this and like we all need a little will
inside 45 minutes later when it's blown
through whatever their funding goal is
I I texted Nathan back and I was like
congratulations do do you still want me
to do it and he was that would be great
if you did would so I did and then
months went by and now everyone I know
is working on con man and I'm getting
sadder and
sadder and drunker and drunker and I'm
buying myself things on Amazon to try to
fill the gaps and I'm just the bottle
are littering my office and I haven't
changed my clothes in like a week and I
get an email and the email says Allan
tudk would love for you to come do this
thing in con man and my response was
what's Chris Hardwick doing that he
wasn't available all
right which is generally my first
response to whenever anyone asks me to
do anything that's great that's not come
on and and they were like he's doing at
midnight and can't make it would you um
would you please come and and do this
and and I said I and I said I didn't
even have to know what it what it was
you didn't have to know what the
character was I said yeah I'm really
excited about this I would love to do it
and it would mean the world to me to
come and be involved in it and um I did
one of those things where I got really
really really lucky where I am in a
scene with funnier and better and more
experienced actors than me and I get one
line and it's hilarious and and it's
like the easiest thing it's one of the
greatest like actor slight of hand
tricks in the
world his again his role is much larger
I have to say um I had hoped to bring
his character you know in it was it was
lucky to bring his character in earlier
so there'll be a call back if we make
more of these well I would imagine I
mean at this point have you been
approached by anyone yet I mean did any
did any larger company go ah interesting
and and try to scoop it
up no oh well I guess that was a very
bad question then I I don't I don't know
uh if you know what that would be like I
mean we'll we'll see if that kind of
thing happens but I don't
know you know we we it was a frustrating
process when we did approach them so I I
don't know what that would be like yeah
and of course you know you talk to
Studio people they're like Allan we
always knew this would be a big hit you
know like they always want to take
credit for [__] and even when they
didn't do anything my my I have to say
my agents fired me
like yeah they can't f you they work for
you what are you talking about like I
they're like it's pilot season I said
you know what I really I've got to focus
cuz the second pilot season I'm like I'm
sitting out for conment I really want to
get this made and they said I said I can
do something in six months and they said
yeah well we'd love for you to do that
with someone else and uh oh my God you
know the suck it list is growing with
you like there are so many people who
can suck it at this point and I hope
that this is the biggest I hope this is
the biggest thing ever because then you
have that moment where people come back
and they're like hey and you're like
that's weird cuz I mean Alan
yeah Alan Allan and I met in 2001 we did
a pilot together which we were convinced
was going to get picked up we played
Brothers all the friends people produced
it so we were already talking about what
cars we were going to buy and uh and it
had an amazing and cast it's like Kathy
morti and leslianne Warren and Dan hidea
and us and uh and then nothing and then
nothing after how do you kill a cactus
that's that was one of the jokes that
was one of my and I came out in my
underwear I was chunkier then and so
that was funny you had a you had a a
jelly donut bit where you bit into the
it was like the last thing like yeah um
you bit into it and had to blob all over
you and that was hilarious Antics yeah
and then after that people were like you
should host things and I'm like okay
uh sounds
good but uh but yeah I mean I think you
know when you look at the scope of this
project and you realize that as I said
all these people are fan favorites it
was funded by fans and it's about fandom
and fans I mean I I think it's just the
sort of the I to be honest I think it's
better that no one got their grubby
corporate Ms on it because you wouldn't
be able to you wouldn't be able to tell
the story in an authentic way without
someone leaning in and screwing BR it up
with fans like the the the group the
people that you see in the background
are fans we were able to give uh
lines what the Guild of extras The Guild
of extras The Guild of extras mhm thank
you they named themselves The Guild of
extras uh but we got to eat lunch hang
out all day long people got lines I mean
it was a it was a lot of fun like the
community didn't stop right there they
came in and we made this together and it
I mean really we really made it together
so and and not just figuratively we made
it together they hung out in that hot
comic book store all day long uh when we
shot there it was so this is really it
was it's it really feels like family
there's so many people on the panel that
I think we should allow some extra time
for Q&A uh so if you want to let me just
let me just really quickly say PJ
harma this could not have been made
without
you uh you know I I feel like people
don't people don't know PJ and also his
daughter is here Skyler who uh is in
spectrum and she's amazing in Spectrum
she's the one with the glowing eyes um
uh she was brilliant and uh what a good
debut for you Skyler no um said what a
but
PJ like you know we call ourselves
producers but PJ's the producer PJ knows
what he's doing and uh honestly you
can't why it looks so good is because of
PJ and that hair yeah that hair that
shock of hair it's it's you're going
make me cry it's just like an ocean wave
crashing on a Shore a gray ocean
gorgeous you Silver Fox uh sky can you
hear us down there sky can you hear it
you can't okay she can't she's not
listening Sky did you have fun working
on this yes thank
you
Skyler Skyler took my direction kind of
poorly because I give I was just so like
it was just
complex so Nathan did all of her
Direction remember use your imagine
Nathan
so we have to create the hashtag
imaginan right now and make it Trend uh
hi what's your name wait have we agreed
on a spelling for imagin Imagine uh i m
a g i n i n a t h a n
imagin
m in
a this is how it happened okay but I'm
just telling you that it looks like
imagine a
then I'm a jithan man all right well
guess what the internet is about to try
to figure out what this
means it's kind of like the first time I
in the winter I hashtag Let It Snow and
all lowercase people are like leits now
like I remember that you remember
that so I had to go in and capitalize
like like Saturday I'm French and I'm
happy about winter what can I say
uh what is what is your name ma'am hi my
name is Sher and what is your question
um my questions for Allan um first of
all Alan I am very honored to be what
the hell
what look at that that's crazy yes how
did you do that so fast you know wait
were you in the were you in it no sir oh
okay how did you do that um I stayed up
till 2:00 in the morning with a bunch of
markers and sewed some stuff that's
awesome my gosh from like set
photos
yeah set set photos you have got to be
con man fan number one like if there was
a fan club you would have to be number
one I I don't know I'm just um honestly
I'm very proud to say that I'm Indiegogo
funer and uh thank you to all the cast
and the crew and everybody that was
involved with kand PJ Nathan Allan
Michael will all you guys
um this is like a dream come true for so
many of us and um Alan you know what you
w you walked out here in your wash
costume but you know what bro I am proud
to represent Alan tudk as Ray nearly as
cash
Wayne thank you very
much my question is um what's been the
most rewarding part for you Alan from
con I want you to ask that question in a
second but Alan put the camera back on
her put the camera back on her Alan
stand in front of that because it's just
going to take too much time and give her
give her a yeah there you go there you
go oh this is going to be good this
gonna be really
good kind
awesome I will make sure and get that to
you thank you very much I will find you
I will
okay so you had a serious question what
was it yes um Alan from from the moment
of conception of con man to now post
production still having fun with it what
has been the most rewarding thing for
you the most rewarding thing is watching
actors and being in a
a when the when I had my director had on
uh watching actors take something that I
wrote that I'll be like there's a joke
here and there's a funny thing here and
there's a funny thing here that I'm
looking forward to doing and then
handing it over to them and watching it
just be funny funny funny funny funny
funny thing that I hadn't even imagined
that just like tro your thing it I mean
from the moment you hey what's going on
I almost shot you I'm sorry no I'm
working through it I'm working through
it wow and like what the hell and it
happened with everybody I mean it would
just that it would just bring me so so
much joy like crazy amount of Joy uh
something I hadn't experienced before uh
not not Joy uh sure CU my first
girlfriend's name was I totally Joy yeah
so there was a lot of wait wait before
you go uh before you go what is your
Twitter handle so I can tweet that
picture at you it's a Shelby pilot
Shelby s h e l b y yes like the car
pilot pilot Shelby and pilot all right
you're going to pick up a ton of follow
followers just now you know that right
your follow just went through the roof
oh I I was blessed to meet you last
summer uh here at nerd HQ and I was
blessed to meet Nathan last year too hi
PJ
um well thank you oh yeah
yeah has ketchup on it though there's
the old the old ketchup hey Chris a
little a little ketchup uh get some
fries with that it'll be great
ironically she's ironically she's never
going to wash it
uh Chris hey Chris Chris hey Chris hard
Chris hard Chris hard you know this one
thing I just want to add something to
what Allan said from our perspective the
idea that somebody who's written
something and made something so
hysterical and giving us the freedom to
do that kind of thing is rare and that
collaborative spirit that was on this
set is like very few things I've ever
worked on were like that so I mean I
mean when you give people that that kind
of freedom I I'm sure everybody would
agree with that I mean he what he wrote
was brilliant and just to be able to add
or or or you know just play with it was
something we all appreciate it only
makes it better you've got one of my
favorite don't give away you've got one
I give away a joke and you gave it to
Mindy so talk about you know being
generous well she needed some
help no Mindy Mindy shots fire Mindy do
you know what line I'm talking about
what do you know what line I'm talking
about when Bobby mentions her first
husband what which one it's at the
ladder remember the ladder oh the ladder
when you stand when you're standing at
the ladder you say been there he says I
you know have I there's a there's a big
don't ruin it I'm not going to ruin it
don't ruin it ruin but she's there
standing a ladder he has a line where he
asks her a question about her sexual
history and uh she answers about her
first husband that's that's that's Nolan
noris line that I actually heard him
first say that joke when we were on the
set of Uncharted so anyway just use your
imagin nice nice time I think the idea
is that we all work together
nicely hi what's your name hello hello
um I'm Maggie or Magdalene and first I'd
like to say thank you to Nathan um you
made my sister Rachel her wish really
special um on the setup Castle so um oh
that's great yeah thank you for that
thank you she really appreciated it and
we appreciated it um oh oh sorry and
then um I'd like to ask what were some
of the hardest things for um just
everybody having it be a fan-funded
thing and a web series I know it's a lot
different so just um what were some of
the hardest things what were some of the
hardest
parts uh I think you know convincing
some agents that was actually the hard
part like when we would approach certain
people that weren't in our immediate
circle
uh to get in contact with their the
actors that they represent to say hey
we're doing this this crowdfunded thing
that they would just blow us off yeah it
is I think I hope you guys understand a
lot of times there there is sort of a
representative firewall where PR people
or agents will just automatically say no
to stuff and then someone will go why
didn't you do this thing you're like I
even know about it you know like so it
it is you are lucky if you have an agent
that will actually say like that has a
little bit of vision and will go hey
this sounds really cool and a lot of
people you know maybe you should do this
thing as opposed to like web series
click you know yep that that was that
was probably the most frustrating thing
I don't know how how hard it was
um you know as a web series you know
it's it's it's kind of a different thing
but we used a lot of the people that we
used who were the crew they were they
were
topnotch right PJ I mean they were like
a lot of them were from Shield uh the
Agents of Shield because they were
off uh our DP Jay was uh he did the much
to do about nothing with you uh and he
he told me a story about you saving his
life yep he saved his life on much or do
about nothing remember George George
actually lit Interstellar what's that
the the gaffer lit Interstellar oh my
gosh and that we did Interstellar yeah
so these these were like you know and I
think it shows when you get to see it or
if you you know watch the trailer
several times whatever you know whatever
you do uh that it looks and you know and
I it looks very well done I I we got
great cameras and great people working
on it but and and continue and we're
going to continue to do that uh in post
um and
I hope we're able to show people and
re-educate people about what the web can
be I mean I think they're all talking
about they want to reach out they're
trying to figure it out and they really
are we talked to a lot of people when we
were shopping this around and they're
all trying to figure out how to how to
milk the money out of it but
uh you know yeah uh so we'll take 90% of
it we'll give you 10 uh you know that's
where the conversation starts um anyway
that that that the idea that the web is
just some little thing uh it can be a
lot of things and uh as we all know um
that Productions Can it can be high
production value and that it can be
hopefully very good yeah because with
digital with web content it's I think
first and foremost because you have to
understand it's a crowdfunded platform
like because people don't watch stuff on
the web unless it's shared to them by
other people who liked it right and I
think first and foremost and actually
that's a good question for Felicia and
will too is that stuff I I think just
needs to be authentic to resonate with
people and you can't fake authenticity
and I think that's why bigger media has
such a problem conquering digital
content because they just look at it as
like oh there's billions of people on
here we gota where do we where do we
squeeze the money out of it but it's it
just doesn't it doesn't work that way
you know it's more about creating
authentic content would you agree with
that Felicia Day I I think that when you
create on the
scale did you ask Felicia cuz you were
looking at me I I'm sorry Felicia I was
talking to will sitting next to you no I
didn't act no both of you both of you
yeah both of you we could both go yeah
you go I'm sorry I oh I'm the worst I'm
the guy that started talking when the
woman was asked the question it no not
at all he was looking he he has a little
tick in his eye it's weird it was like
somewhere here I mean will I feel like
I'm always kind of staring at you it was
both of us uh yes I agree with you the
authenticity and that's why I said when
I read it there's an authentic quality
to Comm man and I think to anything
that's really popular on the web that uh
it's an organic vision
and I think Hollywood tends to sort of
package things in what they think that
people will want focus group it to death
exactly and I think the web is amazing
because the audience can tell people
what they want and encourage it I think
that one of the things that that that
sets apart really welldone web content
from Legacy Media companies trying to
just make a thing and put it on the web
because somehow lots of people see it in
in in some weird way question mark
question mark question mark profit it
they what I think they don't realize is
that when we make something online
there's a legitimate genuine overriding
passion that drives us to create in this
way that makes us feel like it's okay to
get on the phone to our friends and say
look we none of us are getting rich off
of this but we love it and we think it's
really great would you come and do this
with us and that really comes through on
the screen I came onto con man toward
like the LA one of the last days of
production generally when a crew is is
really wiped out especially after a
really long shoot and everybody it felt
like the second day everybody was so
happy to be there and working so hard
together and that comes through to to
the to the audience in a way that like a
focus grouped topd down giant Network
thing just never quite gets there they
can never quite quite cross that like
uncanny valley of like pretending to be
um excited about a thing and being
legitimately excited about a thing I
enjoyed your uh milking yeah that was
I'm very excited this how I talk about
do am I thinking early in the morning
when I'm just out there
right when I'm milking my goats and
we're just talking get a camera on
Casper I think he's milking he's doing a
little bit yeah perfect yep let's just
go down the line there got Satan's
eyeballs and you're thinking about stuff
and I I just learned that will weaton
has the tattoo of a giant octopus on his
arm oh yeah is it a cthulu or is it an
octopus it's I have a tattoo of an
octopus I have a tattoo of my wife's
heartbeat oh I just and I have a tattoo
pinup girl that you can't
see that's so will
weaton uh you guys I'm kind of in a gang
okay can
can bye Michael look at that I I
intimidated tro right off the
stage tro was like [__] I got to
someone's heartbeat on my
arm uh hey what is your what are your
names so I'm Josh this this is oh my God
and Little M oh my God that's
amazing I have to say that is a very
realistic
baby I mean it's moving and everything
that's
incredible you guys look amazing do you
have a colle do you have a a collective
question which one's wash she
is can can a wash go up there is no he's
dead let it go okay
a you can be our
wash all right okay so this is a little
overwhelming this is an amazing panel to
talk to um our question was for Alan and
Nathan Alan when you were coming up with
the show did you think of an idea and
say Nathan will be great for this or
have you guys been working for like a
few years to just get the gang back
together it was part the original idea
that Nathan was that was was the was the
Jack Moore role that he he he was the
one who went on to a great success it
just it fits his
personality it fits our I mean it just
it just fits it fits your life is very
large my friend it is a big life you
know you
you when we were shooting it was you
know part of our scheduling was like
well Nathan's going to be in Australia
you were at cons but but you're in
Australia for this portion of time and
you were there for a few days and then
at the rap party was like Nathan can't
be here cuz he's in Mexico like you're
you're you're moving and then uh Castle
takes up a lot of your time and Jack
Moore yeah to say a lot of your time is
really an is is an understatement uh but
you know Rey is always trying to reach
out and and see his friend Jack and his
life is so big and he's so busy he has
trouble getting a hold of him and uh
which is why Allison's role uh as his
assistant is you know I I end up seeing
her uh she's sort of his representative
he'll be like come over let's go to the
batting cages and I show up the batting
cages and there's Allison
yeah he couldn't make it I'm terrible at
batting cages Allan don't write that
in Allan and I we are dying to work
together we always want to work together
we' love to do that stuff it's never in
our control right until
now yeah I didn't hear that and I really
like that about there's a lot of people
uh in Hollywood who are content to in
the entertainment industry to sit back
and wait till something happens and
resent everyone when it doesn't or there
are the people who say I'm going to make
something happen and it's really neat to
see Allan become that person yeah and
it's
also it's also a good lesson for you
that if you're passionate about
something you should go make your thing
like you should just go make it ab and
don't wait for someone don't wait for
some large corporation to to come in cuz
cuz Will's right most of the Legacy
Media companies except for the heurst
corporation which does fine work um uh
most of the Legacy Media corporations
won't like they just don't think that
way they don't go you can't go well this
is fueled by Passion and people are it's
authentic and people Michael tro came
back
everybody somebody had to take a pee
break I think somebody had to take a PE
break
I know think there was a point I was
like do we just piss him off what
happened just I just leave I don't say
goodbye I had another panel yeah but
anyway it was real
short anyway go go make your thing you
don't need to raise $3 million to make
your thing you can just go make it today
if you want uh it does help though yeah
yeah helps if you're on Firefly and you
can but fine but go make your thing mil
uh what is your name sir I feeline Mike
what is your question uh well I just
want to say my wife sent me up here
because she thought Nathan's Hot so
she's making me ask him a
question sometimes she's just uh back
there tightening the pants she's wearing
clearly pretty much yeah uh my question
is how did you guys determine that
Nathan was going to be the uh Action
Hero is that kind of inspired by the
fact that he's so busy so he's kind of
hard to get a hold of which seems like
it's going on in the
show I'm sorry what's the like how what
I think it was more I think what his
wife wants to know is uh uh how did you
you know find this role for Nathan is
that right like what like what was was
it based on were you kind of basing it
on Nathan or did you was were you
considering it for other
stuff
uh no we wanted to work together and it
just made sense also you
know part of it was you know written
around the idea that we might not be
able to you know he might be shooting
Castle while we were doing it and it
just it kind of that influenced the role
and uh that we would have be need to be
like grabbing him on weekends and things
like that we didn't know in what
capacity we were going to be able to uh
work with you and and all of that so it
just kind of it just fell into place and
made sense and Nathan plays a
good Nathan's a leading man I don't need
to tell y'all
that's DN
Nathan
and Nathan
fillian
what Nathan is Nathan represents the
best alignment which is chaotic good
like he represents yeah he's the he's
the sort of The Lovable scoundrel and it
doesn't matter what he does you just
want to love him no matter what he does
like he's the he's the he's the and I
have a plus four dexterity
vest that helps thank you Mike thank
thank you very much hello smells like
wow wow nice oh I'm sorry the
microphone's not working oh there go
okay hello hi so we are part of the what
was it the Guild of extras that were yes
that were you guys called all right so
we're a team um and we just wanted to
say even though there was absolutely no
pay it was a true honor to be on there
we came running as soon as we heard like
are you kidding we stumbled over each
other with our outfits and everything to
be a part of your your show I just just
want to say whenever I don't know about
everyone else in this room I'm pretty
sure they can understand that when you
have a shitty week you throw on Firefly
and life is good
yeah period like so the idea that you
are coming back even in a spoof version
of this makes all of us want to cry a
little bit and we're shut up and take
our money so and then you have the Epic
cast of fandom that you just decided to
bring it just for fun that's good that's
good so we just wanted to say we love
you guys thank you for all the work
you're doing thank you for being in it
PJ did they really not get paid what oh
this is awkward don't ask I I didn't get
don't ask questions don't ask questions
you don't want the answers to that could
be a I believe you can have extras or
you can have a cave Allan make your
choice what was your what was your name
sir uh I am Brandon uh hillock um and
this is uh my team from uh the Looking
Glass Wars excellent Brandon I'll be
expecting a royalty check from white
guys who look similar which includes me
Charlie Day Matt Bellamy and Aaron Paul
done uh so we'll be looking for that
those are tattoos of me you hear we'd
like to say thank you so you got some
tattoos of alen's face yep being Del and
in this it's a spectrum uh a spectrum a
spectrum thing yeah really sweet thank
you so much the next person gets some
ketchup you guys do look amazing by the
way signed by me wa you are literally
signing that ketchup yes I am
it's the first bottle of ketchup I've
signed
so there be many more there there we go
hi what's your name hi I'm Melissa um
first of all love you
guys hi hello um my sister Amanda says
hi my Caitlyn my friend Caitlyn says Hi
um this is for Alan Nathan and Felicia
when you first decided to pursue acting
did you have like a goal or someone that
you wanted to work with is like yeah I
did it ah thank you yeah who's someone
that you wanted to work with that you
finally were able to work with oh that I
was able to
yeah Jos weed
yeah that's not a
lie wow you know I auditioned for Buffy
didn't get
it but you still got to be in the series
though yeah yeah yeah but he auditioned
for Buffy I mean you need to tell the
whole story and he almost got it too
he's good yeah I am an
actor the one thing I can't do is act
small who did you who did you audition
for in Buffy Angel you audition for
Angel yeah David was awesome
though has anyone ever seen an episode
of Bones what happens on that show I've
never seen bones it's been on for a
while bones or as I like to call it the
other
Castle
wow that was amazing
Castle 2 going out they don't come back
here but lady at least they can hear hi
button lady they can hear hi those are
all in her flesh wow oh hey you were on
set activate her microphone I was on set
yes I want to thank you Alan for
treating the extras so nicely and so
personably and not being afraid of us
and hopefully nothing horrible happened
with your fans touching no there was a
cake that day wasn't there Alan was this
the uh the con
scenes yes yeah I oh right that's right
so you saw Jerry Lancing I did see Jerry
Lancing he was
amazing I apologize for everything and
anything I said I I wish there was a
longer reel of just your your adbs oh no
no they'll take my kids
away they've called they've called uh
hopefully your cast and crew enjoyed the
buttons that I gave them and uh my
question is when is that trailer going
to be appropriately available online and
when season two oh season two yeah so
the trailer is available when 600 p.m.
tonight 6 p.m.
tonight and season 2 what about season 2
is that season 2 6
p.m. well we we we'd love to do a season
two obviously we're going to see how
this one goes um uh if it's
popular you know I I was thinking about
this what if if you know if if this
thing is popular what does that mean and
I think it means if you create something
and people like it then you get to
create more and so I have I have so many
stories and I'm sure a lot of you do as
well now that you know when people found
out about this people will approach and
go oh you got to hear this story oh my
God and they're really good uh so keep
coming with those uh and uh we're going
to pass a collection plate around for $3
million uh we hope we hope the next time
around to um well you know we don't know
what the next season will be but we hope
to uh use somebody else's money uh yeah
I mean I think the important thing is
you guys like you know watch it support
fan-made stuff spread you know send it
to all of your friends because that's
the only way that this works and that
they would be able to make more so you
you have some responsibility if you like
stuff you are now empowered to to make
that manifest uh in real life so so when
you watch it spread it around spread the
word tell everyone about about con man
thank you so much Buton lady I think we
just have time for one more question
what is your name hi my name is Kate and
I just wanted to say uh congratulations
Alan I am looking forward to my Cameo
and con
man my question is for Ellen and Nathan
and it
is um what are you personally a big fan
of and what is the craziest thing you've
done as a fan of it oh yeah so what are
you fan of and then how did your fandom
Express itself in a crazy way uh I'm a
fan of Walking Dead in Game of
Thrones you heard of it a friend of mine
owns a uh wolf hybrid that looks a lot
like a
wolf and I did a little photo shoot with
it oh and I'm
proud uh also your other friend host
talking dead but don't worry about this
V uh Alan uh I'm a fan of Gotham
uh and I met the penguin uh at a con uh
whose name is everyone
together
Robin we're friends Robin Lord tayor
Taylor Robin Lord Taylor I said that y
uh uh the microphone just got gar but
you said tough It's a Reverb uh but I
met him and I was pretty goofy around
him like wow you're so good I mean wow
it's really good to me you just really
love your performance I mean every week
you really deliver so that was that was
recently
um I forget it's been a lot I've had
several so that but that's the most
recent yeah let's I think this is a
great way to end everyone kind of go
down and just name someone that you were
nervous that you met and how that went
really really quickly oh God Nathan
fillian yes nervous that you met I can't
believe I'm sitting next to
him this is not a joke but as a huge
Star Trek fan when I met will weaton I
lost it it was at
ComiCon it was at Comic Con and will and
I met backstage at Hardwick show and
like nerded out over Doctor Who together
and then like had a dance party
somewhere and then we were like we
should be friends and I was like I'm
friends with will
weaton we had Harrison Ford in the
podcast a couple years ago and I could
not contain my fandom so it's the most
nervous I've ever been on a podcast and
he's funny because he's half pretends to
be cranky and then is half kind of
cranky and uh so I was like you know
hard is not to ask you questions about
the Indiana Jones and Star Wars and he
was like try harder uh
which to him was probably hilar because
he he did a panel in here I moderated a
panel in here and the first person that
asked the question was like uh M and
he's probably gotten this for decades
like Mr Ford uh big fan I was just
wondering what would Indiana Jones say
if he met Han Solo and Harrison Ford
just goes ah
hello
sound I withdraw my
question
Nolan
um mine is actually different I was I
was named after Nolan Ryan the the
famous baseball player and uh in high
school I was actually scouted by the
Texas Rangers and I got to go up to I
lived in New England and I got to go up
to meet the general manager and the and
go out on Fenway Park and meet them and
and then Nolan Ryan came from doing his
warm-ups and he started walking at me
and I swear as he got closer I just got
smaller and and it was just and I sat in
the Dugout U at Fenway Park with him for
about 20 minutes and talked B and I
remember sitting there like I was eight
and it just I could to this day it just
gives me goosebumps yeah that that'd be
it uh what about you
Casper Mine mine's a baseball one too I
uh I got to meet uh Reggie Jackson I was
doing promo for Sleepy Hollow in New
York and uh Reggie Jackson walked up and
he goes I have no idea who you are but
he went right right up to my wife he
goes but I know who you are and I'm like
Reggie Jackson's hit up my
wife love my wife and my wife is like
who's Reggie Jackson oh my God this is
the best day of my
life and then the next day I saw him in
the gym and I'm on the treadmill I'm
running next to him like hi Reggie and
and he goes oh my God and I'm like oh so
anyhow Reggie um and then I tripped and
fell and right off the treadmill went
that way and I got right back on I
started running and I'm like oh sorry
I'm okay and he goes you know she's way
out of your
league that is
amazing that is amazing TR do you have
one
true
story mine's also a um a sports one I
was I participated in the uh a pro
celebrity football game two years ago
and I I've never played football in my
life and there's only two girls you know
the token girls were on it we never got
thrown to it all and but in practice Dan
Marina was my quarterback and uh in
practice he could see that one of the
girls and I were kind of throwing it
back and forth and like oh she's she's
kind of athletic that's that's that's
good I'm gonna throw it to her I got to
throw it to a girl so they'd been
throwing it to the guys and I've been
watching their plays you know they run
up this way and then they cut that way
and then they turn around and the balls
floating to them great so Dan comes out
to me he's like all right I'm going to
throw tea this time and there's a
specialty spot where if you if you you
know catch it in this spot we get extra
points so I'm like yes I'm going to run
right there nobody's looking for the
girl I run right there then I go to turn
and think I've got like another 10t to
run like all the other plays and that
bullet hit me so fast it was like it was
right to the spot it was not one of
those plays but because I don't know the
plays and I caught it and I fumbled
oh he didn't really want to SP to speak
to me after
that what about you Mindy
Sterling um for me uh I got a chance to
meet and work with Warren batty oh and
we were talking and he was talking to me
and and really liking me we're just you
know going on and sharing and he said
you know what I'm going to invite you to
my Christmas party and I said oh my God
that's great oh can I bring my can I
bring my
son that'd be so awesome thank you so
much and I never heard from him again
what
oh you son of a [__] Warren
B how dare you Felicia uh Sean look card
I I'm in a green room he has no name he
has no other name that man he's so
handsome go why you look at me like that
he has no other name really okay he has
another name but when I saw him he just
his glory I saw him in a unitard it was
all I
saw I was an idiot I was such an
[__] will can Will can I can I will
can I tell the Patrick Stewart story
from when you guys please if you're
going to tell the one I think you're
going to tell Patrick Stewart apparently
was humorless in the beginning of Star
Trek and then they all kind of got
together and they're like you need to
light up and he was like okay
so there will and I were actually
friends during when he was doing Star
Trek and uh and so they would shoot
these scenes and then uh Patrick would
just in the middle of the scene go andon
Crusher set a calls for Vector 5 and
then come here and give me a
blow
true
story you know ENT Crusher when a
Grecian General would take a young boy
out on
campaign true
story and he got very funny who totally
true who was yours um I hope you all got
to watch Felicia's emotional Journey
during Mindy's war and B story cuz that
was pretty incredible so I was at I was
at a convention
uh just recently like probably two
months or so ago up in Ottawa Canada and
and um and Billy Piper was there
oh and I am I I I a ginormous dror who
fan um and uh I was like not g to be I I
was going to be cool and and I was I was
not going to like I wasn't going to turn
into the the thing I turn into when like
when I met Henry Rollins like I'm not
going to do that and Marina certis uh
who played counselor Troy on Next
Generation who's a good friend of mine
knows Billy Piper really well and she's
like oh come on I'm going to introduce
you and I'm like I don't know and then
I'm in front of Billy Piper and I'm like
um hi I love
you uh and I'm not going to do to you
what people do to me sometimes but oh my
God I'm doing it and when you were and I
love Doctor Who but see your daugh to
call girl is amazing and I just I just
think you're really great and you're so
pretty and you're and Billy Piper stands
up and hugs me a and she kisses me on
the cheek which is why I have a giant
beard because I don't ever want to wash
my face and and she says you are lovely
it is such a pleasure to meet you my
love
oh Alan do you have one one more uh
thing yes yes yes yes yes I haven't
introduced I haven't introduced you guys
uh Billy and Barry I'm very
sorry
up because because you guys just come
out here come out here come out here uh
these guys are really really really
really important to um con man and to
Spectrum B Billy here did all of the uh
VFX which you saw
and what's
that oh and Kevin's here too he's in the
audience who also has been staying up
for 16 hours uh doing uh make making
what you guys saw and it was the last
thing we shot so they I mean how many
days uh for what now what to do the
trailer how many days oh yeah yeah um uh
I don't know we wrapped on Tuesday so I
haven't had lot of sleep and you know
he's said no sleep
he and Barry so in in the in the in the
trailer you see uh the the uh zombies
that's actually Billy is one of the
zombies and Kevin and Kevin is the other
zombie which is so perfect um I did the
makeup and Barry did the makeup and you
guys what's great in uh keeping in the
whole family tradition of this of con
man where it all just felt like we're
all together you guys are actually
together that is true
um we are actually
uh we are indeed business partners with
uh mind and machine visual effects and
in addition to that we are actually life
partners and he's been wondering why the
hell I'm sitting up here with all these
other people that he worked with all
this time
and I have a surprise for for
him they were asking the cast a minuto
who was the most amazing person you've
met and worked with in Hollywood and I
just want to
say Billy Brooks I love you with all my
heart and soul and will you please marry
me
I don't
know
it's oh my
God